siempre tengo problemas con la palabra
berraquera me gusta es una palabra
calidad coloquial relajada pero primero
no sé si se escribe con be grande o
pequeña siempre me confundo y segundo es
imposible de traducir a otros idiomas
igual me gusta usarla bastante sino que
definirla es bastante complejo tanto en
la vida como el deporte nos enseñan que
a veces se gana ya veces hace año y
medio estábamos jugando contra santa fe
en el campín todos soñamos con jugar en
ese gran estadio sin embargo mi primer
recuerdo ahí no es muy bonito
anoche recuerdo perfectamente me
metieron 6 goles y estábamos jugando
preliminar a los hombres antes de
américa así que hay un montón de gente
en el estadio que pasó sería bueno
aparte de los 6 goles se acabó el
partido obviamente super frustrada
preocupada búsqueda triste pero el
partido se acabó me duché los muxes
calmaron llegué a mi casa cn me acosté a
dormir y al otro día me levanté
y trabajando
año y medio después volvimos a enfrentar
a santa fe en el campín pero esta vez la
historia fue diferente esta vez ganamos
nosotras 20 que pasó ese día se acabó el
partido
disfrutamos en el camerino nos duchamos
de casas y me acosté y al otro día me
levanté a seguir trabajando
siempre nos hablan de que hay que tener
berraquera para levantarnos de las
derrotas pero pocos nos mencionan que
también se necesita verdad quiera para
no quedarnos en la victoria al otro día
hay que levantarse desayunar y seguir
entrenando así que berraquera es
levantarse independientemente del
resultado y seguir avanzando
hay contextos que nos frustran a todos
el personal es el fútbol femenino como
algunos conocerán un poco la historia
desafortunadamente lo que pasa en fifa
se ve reflejado en sus asociados fracaso
es conmebol y la federación el proceso
del fútbol femenino viene viene
creciendo viene ahí pero llevamos
nosotros 20 años más de 20 años
trabajando por mejorar nuestras
condiciones laborales y tener que
enfrentarnos a estos ríos donde muchos
de los ideales que ya existen son
considerados como la única verdad es
bastante complejo y ha implicado
levantar la mano alzar la voz y decir
vengan esto no está bien y eso tiene que
cambiar pero en todo este proceso de
reunión en reunión en espacios para sus
contextos aprendí que muchas veces tener
verdad que era es saber
en qué momento de guardar silencio hace
que ocho meses comienzos de este año
estábamos en una reunión muy importante
para salvar la liga profesional
bienvenida en colombia y se quería
acabar la reunión duró más o menos dos
horas llegamos a un acuerdo entre
comillas o no nos dejaron claro más o
menos cuánto costaba la liga llegamos a
una cifra perfecto y teníamos que salir
a atender a los medios
recuerdo que salimos tranquilos cuando
empezamos a atender a los medios una de
las personas que estaba en la reunión
dice una cifra completamente diferente a
la que había mostrado pues en mutuo
acuerdo cuando estábamos hace 10 minutos
en la reunión un momento bastante
frustrante porque pues éste iba a
complejizar el camino de nosotros en el
mundo profesional pero tenía dos
opciones o me quedaba callada o al salam
o la voz y generaba más polémica el
momento entendí que no era ni el momento
ni tenía la manera correcta o ideal de
decir las cosas y requirió de muchísima
berraquera
aguantarme lo y como decimos nosotros
tragarme el sap eres el sapo es el ego
la misma función la radio pero implica
verdad que era saber callar no solamente
futbolistas estamos en una lucha todas
las mujeres en el mundo estamos en eso
de ir abriéndonos espacio y tanto el
complejo además de estar en un mundo que
parece no estar construidas para no
en el mundo del fútbol si nos dicen
seguido unas barracas cómo llegan y
rompen estos techos de cristal para las
nuevas generaciones y si sigue muy
chévere y llegamos todos con un martillo
a romperlos pero en este proceso también
me ha dado cuenta que se necesitan más
dejar de construir techos de cristal
desafortunadamente la mayoría de las
veces somos nosotros mismos las que
ayudamos por lo menos ayudamos a
construir estos techos sería mucho más
fácil la labor si simplemente no
existieran pero para poder lograr eso
requerimos de ir abriendo los ojos y
esto duele duele desaprender duele
cuestionar e incómoda pero por eso se
necesita berraquera para dejar de
construir techos de cristal
es imposible hablar de berraquera si no
hablamos del miedo
hace tres años tuve la gran fortuna de
debutar con las colombia mayores estamos
en chile era la última fecha fifa antes
de jugar copa américa que es donde nos
jugamos el cupo al mundial a los
olímpicos panamericanos la grande la
cosa y recuerdo que ese día por cosas de
la vida me tocó debutar ya el técnico y
se me acerca y me dice vanessa le tocó
pero pilas no la va a embarrar y todos
sabemos que cuando nos dicen no la
embargo es lo primero que uno hace
entonces obviamente generó mucha más
presión habían muchas expectativas
propias y también externas pero mejor
dicho esa noche anterior dormir
relativamente bien al otro día me
levanté no tengo hombre muy callada ese
día y llegó la hora a montarnos al bus
recuerdo me senté en el bus y comenzamos
por fuera pues no tenía whatsapp para
hablar con mi familia ni amigos entonces
estaba literal sola
arrancamos el camino al estadio cuando
me empiezan a temblar las manos y las
piernas literal las manos y las piernas
tiemblan me provocaba decir al conductor
venga para el bus yo me daba cada
solución en esto no es para mí pero no
decidí quedarme sentada seguir y llegar
al estadio el clima del escenario estaba
perfecto el sol estaba afuera no estaba
ni muy calientes ni muy frío estaban las
montañas atrás me encantan las montañas
entonces está o mejor dicho me mandaba a
hacer llegamos al camerino obviamente
todavía seguía temblando cuando tenemos
que salir a calentar y para un momento
dije oh acepto el miedo o la oí apartar
o esto me va a paralizar y va a ser una
noche fatal y yo no voy a permitir que
el miedo me impidiera poder tener
recuerdo amable independientemente que
fuese a pasar en los siguientes 90
minutos podríamos perder podríamos ganar
o empatar no sabía pero no iba a
permitir que el rechazo al miedo
me limitará a un poder generar lindos
recuerdos además recuerdos inolvidables
como el debut de uno es que hice ese día
le di la mano al miedo y salí a la
cancha
afortunadamente ese día empatamos 0-0
por lo menos mi labor la cumplí y hoy lo
recuerdo con mucha alegría y mucha
tranquilidad
ese día aprendí que muchas veces es
tener berraquera es poder darle la mano
al miedo a ellos tenemos que cerrar los
ojos momenticos recordar donde estamos y
para dónde vamos pero está bien hay que
invitarlo al camino y seguir andando
casi pensamos qué verdad que era es
subir el everest verdad ir a correr la
maratón hacer una german pero nos
olvidamos de los momentos
berraquera es acercarte la persona que
te gusta invitarla a salir porque ojo
nos puede decir no nos puede decir que
si no sabemos pero a qué hora también es
poder grabado lavarnos del colegio
grabarnos de la universidad ir a vivir a
otro país pararse a hacer una charla ter
eso eso también es de rockera y no lo
valoramos en la vida nos dan la
oportunidad de definir ciertas palabras
o que ciertas palabras tengan más de una
definición y si quiero que ustedes se
lleven algo algo del día de hoy es que
ustedes tiene el poder el privilegio de
definir la palabra berraquera así que
saquen el jugo a esta linda palabra y
disfruten se la muchas gracias